um and then what's another obvious one i
mean austin powell's gold members before
you get to these ones yeah explain
explain the japanese films
explain the nihongos wait which one do
you want to hear about the first one the
top one the top one okay so
more
so this was during a time this was
during like a very uh
i guess pretentious period of my high
school life where i was like i want to
watch a lot of really old films okay so
darshan is one uh it's done by this guy
called akira kurosawa
i'm a pretentious film boss
so i sat down and watched every akira
kurosawa film and
is one of them and it's essentially it's
really hard to kind of explain but
basically i think this movie was made in
like
1950 i think yeah yeah black and white
film but basically it revolves around
this like one murder case that happens
in like edo period japan and it's and
the same uh i guess murder is told from
different perspectives and different
characters so like it kind of plays
around i don't know if it was the first
movie to ever do it but it kind of plays
around with the whole like unreliable
narrator like logic that a lot of movies
use now and it's just like
i don't know the cinematography in it is
like it's hard to believe this movie was
made 70 years ago yeah i mean that's why
every [ __ ] big director in their big
film buff still says his name
director's favorite director yeah yeah
yeah yeah basically yeah and then like i
i feel that darshan was one of those
movies that like took
everything that akira curacao was like
really good at in terms of filmmaking
yeah just like crushed it into like an
hour 30 minutes like solid movie and
like mifune toshiro is like the guy in
the poster who's in like basically every
[ __ ] akira kurosawa movie but like
he's one of my favorite japanese actors
just because like i don't know
he he kind of you know there's that like
weird stigma of japanese acting where
it's like way over the top and like
really unrealistic yeah we've talked
about it which we've talked about like
mifune toshiro in my opinion like kind
of took that and almost made it his own
yeah because like every mufune toshiro
character is like so over exaggerated in
terms of like emotion and like movement
and stuff like that like i'd be very
surprised if he didn't do like theater
training yeah and [ __ ] like that but
like i don't know it's over exaggerated
but it's still like
believable if that makes sense okay and
it's like it becomes really like kind of
i don't know what the right word for it
is i know i sound very pretentious right
now but
but it's a real go ahead
but like in my opinion
like there's lots of really good
accuracy movies i think the only one
i've seen is seven samurai seven
samurais
the classic yeah that's that's the one
where that like fight scene goes on for
so goddamn long that might be the i mean
there's a lot of like that was a really
weird
did i have a remake so there was a
western remy yeah there was a western
remake also the magnificent seven is the
western
version of that film uh which is also a
classic i think maybe i'll watch what
are they called 13 assassins that's a
remake right of uh that's
i don't know actually
i think that's the thing
is it yeah yeah is that a really really
long fight in seven sam right uh i don't
know about seven samurai but like the
one that i can think of that has a
really long fight is probably iran
i don't know
you've probably seen seven samurai if
you've gone through if you went through
the phrase of going through like the
imdb top you've probably seen it
about
that was in black and white and there
was a there was a fight scene yeah that
was like two hours long and i was just
like sitting there like what is when is
it gonna end i don't know about i don't
think seven samurai was even two hours
long yeah no it was it was it was like
three and a half hours long
so i don't remember the check
yeah is there a long fight scene in
seven sounds
that was just a very long movie
like long long fights i mean it's
probably the scene it's probably the
film you're thinking i want to know if
i've watched it you've probably seen it
it's it's it's a classic like it's
definitely on the imdb like there's
probably about five accuracy films if
you go through the imdb no it's actually
only one it's a it's only seven samurai
i was about to say
um because i see anyone here that's on
the imdb top 250. so that's the only one
that most people have only seen probably
even though he has like such a wealth of
work yeah i mean ron was i think his
first color film and that was also
[ __ ] fantastic i think i think the
stigma is that a lot of the kiara
kurosawa films are like based around
like samurai and [ __ ] like that when
like later on in his career he did a lot
of like kind of
rooted more in like modern day stuff
there's there's another film that i
thought about putting up there called
ikiru which means to live yeah and it's
essentially this like kind of
coming-of-age story of this old man who
realizes that he's like about to die and
basically like you know the movie the
bucket list with [ __ ] yeah like
morgan jack and jack nicholson i feel
that
completely ripped off of the cure
because it's it's almost like because
the concept is exactly the same it's
like an old guy wanting to like kind of
rediscover his life and like really like
give meaning to his life on his deathbed
okay but like told him like a really
like cool artistic accuracy
right um yeah i don't know yeah i mean
he he's a legend for a reason oh he's
allegedly in the film industry if you're
a movie bluff please watch akira
kurosawa what's this i've never okay
is uh this is it's a zombie movie right
yeah so basically it's this movie have
you seen it yeah it's okay i was not
expecting anything out of this movie so
i actually watched this film when did it
come up
it very it's quite quite recently it's
like a couple years ago yeah so i
thought it was just gonna be like okay
so the reason why i think this movie is
genius is the way that it was marketed
so the way that it's marketed you look
at this poster and you think oh it's a
zombie film yeah like a b grade zombie
film kind of thing okay it's completely
not it basically takes the zombie film
thing and turns it super [ __ ] metal
so basically what it is it's like i
don't want to give too much away but
basically the movie opens with this
15 20 minute one cut zombie film okay
like there's no cuts in it whatsoever
and then you think oh the credits roll
and that's it but then what happens is
it goes back and it shows you how that
one cut movie is made but told in a
fictional way
it's really difficult it's really
[ __ ] meta it's basically that sounds
cool it's basically a movie
on and there's like all sorts of like
weird like it's actually a comedy
there's also like there's all these like
weird comedic shenanigans that happen
behind the scenes of them shooting that
one-shot 20-minute zombie film so the
movie is about the making of that movie
that honestly sounds like it's right up
my alley yeah and it's i think you'd
you'd like that i'm just like this is
this that's the thumbnail
recording right there
it's like i'll make a [ __ ] video on
this i was i was not expecting this
movie to be good at all but it was one
it's really really funny and two again
like the whole meta aesthetic of it i
was like whoa i've never and what it
gets even more meta because during the
credit scenes then there's a
behind-the-scenes camera of that camera
okay so it's like a movie within a movie
within a movie
and it's like i love it i just love like
the whole meta aesthetic of it but like
i put this on there because like for one
i barely know anyone who's seen it i've
never even heard of it you'd like yeah i
guess people will know yeah the english
title is one cut of the dead one one cut
off yeah that sounds so cliche though
but that's exactly it right like it
plays to the strengths of zombie film
cliches it just completely flips it on
its head and just turns it into like
this wacky slapstick comedy
yeah and it's really really cool it
sounds like an episode of harahi or
something right yeah honestly
because like your favorite game yeah
sorry it came out in 2017 i forgot like
2007 2017. yeah yeah i mean i feel like
the last zombie movie that i watched
that i really [ __ ] enjoyed was
trained to busan oh that's good
fantastic movie so good and like i can't
explain why it's really good because
it's just like a very like it
it has like the same beats as just a
standard zombie movie but it's just just
just a really good movie it's a solid
movie this is a solid movie even though
even if like you think you're bored of
the zombie genre
like i think i am sorry because i
thought okay if you're bored of the
zombie genre you need to watch that and
then i gotta watch 20 they're gonna
watch other [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
no but like uh one cut of the dead it
was that was the time yeah one cut of
the day like yeah like i feel if there's
any movie i can recommend on my three by
three it's probably that one just
because it's like it comes like both put
it in the bottom right as well like the
bottom left sorry like it completely
destroys what you think about movies
yeah okay in a way that's like really
fun and also like just again it's just
meta as [ __ ] if you want that whole meta
thing like you'd love them